so did you always know because it's such
a
it's a it's it's a job where I think a
few have really excelled as much as you
and like Dick Clark like there's there's
there's few that have have gotten that
status towards just like oh my God
that's like such a pop culture icon
right so there's very few so that's job
well done but also like what were you
like as a kid did you always want to do
something like this so as a kid I wanted
to be on the TV show CHiPs as a uh
California Highway Patrol biker
policeman yeah I wanted to be you know
poncharella or John Baker one of those
guys on the bike so I pretended to do
that in the neighborhood on my uh
Schwinn and I got they I got from
Service Merchandise a siren and I
pretended I was a CHP officer well then
I realized not for me so I also bought a
Radio Shack mixer when I was a kid and I
pretended to be Casey case I'm counting
down the hits to be a DJ yeah yeah and
when I sort of really got into recording
on cassettes I offered to do outgoing
message is for answering machines at the
time so I would say to my mom should I
could I do the outgoing message for the
Seacrest family on the little micro tape
yeah or to the neighbors listen I'd love
to do the outgoing message for the
Tuckers down the street you've reached
the Tucker residence they're not home
right now but after the beep you can
leave a message and I would try and
charge them for that it's an interesting
kid
um I was a little different it worked
out it worked out
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]